if you go back in time you realize how
much simpler digital messaging was in
the late 90s most people are on AOL
Instant Messenger then we moved on to
basic text messaging now I've got
messages from tons of different services
flying at me in every direction yeah I
get it
choice is good but this this is just
overwhelming can't we just all gather in
one app and have meaningful
conversations there but the question is
where standard text messaging is good
but it's not group friendly my message
is what you have to have an iPhone then
there's blackberry messenger and Google
Hangouts but they're actually not as
good as some of these new apps that have
arrived yes we are at the dawn of a new
mobile messaging era as you might have
heard Facebook has acquired whatsapp for
over 19 billion dollars and then there
are other apps that do similar things so
I went on a journey a mobile messaging
journey to test that pour of these
popular services kik viber whatsapp and
another call to WeChat to see where we
should find our messaging at home all of
these messaging apps work in pretty much
the same way you download the iPhone
Android or Windows Phone app put in your
phone number and then the app scans your
address book to identify contacts who
are on the service you can then send
chats to people privately or group
message
is really different in text messaging
that's my mom and that was one of her
first questions that she had when I
asked her to start testing some of these
absolutely but she quickly didn't figure
out why these were better than text
messaging she saw that there were extra
features like voice notes and she said
that they felt speedier so we got to
testing first with whatsapp the best
thing about whatsapp is how easy it is
to get started and create group chats my
mom and dad loved receiving instant
voice messages from me and my sister
it's also really easy to throw in photos
and fun video but the app actually lacks
a lot of features that the others have
such as animated stickers and other fun
multimedia but that's what we loved
about kik the service is already really
popular with teens and that's because of
the visual aspect of the messaging it
goes way beyond text you can easily put
in images YouTube videos from the web
fun stickers and even put your own words
into popular meme photos right from the
app there's also a really fun sketching
feature it's a lot of fun to play with
but it's also confusing and cluttered
just like a teenager's brain then we
moved on to WeChat which is extremely
popular in China and has even more trips
it has a large selection of stickers
including ones from your favorite Pixar
and Disney characters yes I did pay a
dollar for those monsters University
stickers and in addition to voice notes
and videos it also has an amusing
walkie-talkie mode breaker breaker
what's your 20
but for all those fun features which has
overall interfaces dull and it lacks
expected perks like showing when a
message has been delivered also my mom
and some other friends found this one to
be the hardest to set up and to start
using group chat our last stop was an
app called viber which is much more
focused on audio problems in addition to
audio messages you can do whole calling
over Wi-Fi or your data connection the
app also has a nice selection of fun
stickers and lets you easily send a
doodle or a doodle on top of a photo but
viber still hasn't been updated for iOS
7 so it still has the old keyboard on
the iPhone and in general it's just that
as cleanly designed as some of the
others so my journey ended where it
began with an edict that my friends and
families start using whatsapp why I
liked all the other services whatsapp
was just the easiest to use and get
started with that said I'd still like to
see it get some web chat features and
some stickers I'm probably never gonna
get all my friends and family on one
service anymore but I'm betting that
most people start to join some of these
that or we could go back in time and pop
on AOL